Jade is with us Jade is in Tennessee hi
Jade welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how
can we help
hey they even Anthony how are y'all
doing great how can we help okay so I am
blessed this day I'm attending my dream
school University of Tennessee I just
finished up my freshman year but you
know attending UT comes to the cross and
I unfortunately had to take out a
student loan this year and um I got a
scholarship for the rest of my time at
UT that will pay for all of you know
tuition and mandatory fees don't
wondering what I can do now to pay off
the loan that I have so I won't like
have so much money and interest when I
graduate I know what I'm already have a
job I make monthly payments as it is but
I'm wondering how much money I should
put like do I put my whole paycheck so
how do you borrow it would ended up
being like twenty one thousand for one
year yes the University of Tennessee's
nine thousand yeah well it was you're
doing stuff like that as well yeah yeah
I'm a freshman glad to live on campus
and it's expensive no plan and what were
you working out right now J I work for a
course attraction in Chattanooga okay
and how much are you making about I make
around I'd say like five hundred six
hundred dollars
I'm not working right now to do with it
was a whole tone of our thing yeah so
you've got the rest of your years
figured out where you go without more
debt correct yes and you treat your
interest in payments do not begin until
six months after graduation right yes I
would let us sit there and gradually
absolutely yeah I would let it sit there
until you graduate and I would use every
dollar that you can find a pile up to
make sure you complete the degree
without any additional debt
sure first go then we'll worry about
getting a student loan paid off after
you graduate what are you studying human
resource management okay so good job
that's going right there Jay here listen
Dave said it and that's exactly what I
was gonna say and I'm gonna say it just
a little more boater for you let it sit
there and why are you working save all
of your money do not go out as much as
possible enjoy the college experience
you know you're at a great school dave
ramsey was over here smiling when you
said it yeah so you know it's a great
school but i want you to be young and
wise not young and dumb okay so young
and wise is i'm working i'm gonna get
through school I'm gonna make sure I
borrow nothing I'm not gonna touch any
credit cards I'm not gonna make any dumb
decisions and just you should be able to
graduate making five or six hundred
dollars a month you should be able to
graduate five to ten thousand dollars if
you do it right and then you can take
that and put that towards your student
loans as soon as you graduate but the
key thing here is Jade is do not touch
any more debt you hear me
and after the coronaviruses over if you
can even work more work more yeah
$20,000 in your bank account when you
graduate that wouldn't make me mad nope
will make me happy cuz then you could
write a check of my office you could
write a check pay off the student loan
as soon as you graduate that's the thing
and so I guess doing this show for so
many years I have trained to myself I
didn't always do this to listen to the
words that people use the words that she
used made her sound like she really felt
she had no other alternative she was
trapped forced to couldn't have done it
otherwise right thing and really that
was not true it wasn't true I mean
because look at it she ended up getting
the scholarships I just feel as if
sometimes she's literally you're late
exactly and so I think sometimes people
are not willing to put in the work and
to be patient for it to come to pass
and so I'm with you Dave it's I hate
hearing it well I had to take out
the car where I had to take out this no
you didn't you chose to go this route
when you could have went a different
route that would eventually have led you
to the route where you want it to be at
so and that's what the book 3 degree is
really all about it's about showing you
the you know the things you have to do
you have to get scholarships you have to
work a lot yes you have to choose the
right school to choose an inexpensive
school yes sir and you don't have to
choose the most expensive meal plan she
did so she did that yeah she's so she's
realizing a few of the things she
tripped up on but more than anything
what I want you guys to work with your
young people on out there and you young
people anything are always harping on
this is that debt-free degree is as much
as anything it starts with the proper
mindset yes that you're not trapped yes
you have options yes sir
and that that's why the book became a
number-one bestseller because it walks
you through that and so you know if you
say well I'm you know I'm going to XYZ
famous school and I can't afford it so
I'm trapped well no you're not trapped
you're just going to you know is you're
going to a Bentley dealership when you
have used Chevrolet money come on Dave
you know and so that's what you've got
you just need to stay off the Bentley
lot you have to and Dave last night I
was on IG live on my Instagram and I met
a young lady she came on with me and she
got her master's degree as a single
mother unfortunately she had a you know
a baby when in earlier earlier years and
her bachelor's program but she said I
did not want to graduate with any debt
and so she went a long period of time
took the semester time but she graduated
100% debt-free and she's a schoolteacher
now and she's not making that much money
but she's debt-free with the young boy
and she said I just made the sacrifices
from listening to Dave and I just didn't
want it and so when I hear people say
like that I'm a single mother I worked
my way through school and when I heard
other people say well I had to well I
get confused know what I'd i think the
lesson we take away from this was not
that she's Jade's not a bad lady she
does it's gonna be fine she doesn't
she'll work her way through this will
help or we're not we're not picking on
Jade that's not the point
yeah but I think the point is for
everyone to listen to the words you're
using because they may reveal what's
going on in your heart that you need to
shift but since you can decide that I'm
not trapped yeah yeah as a matter of
fact I'm an old hillbilly soon as you
start telling me I'm trapped I'm about
to fight don't try to track me it's not
a good idea I don't like being trapped
that's B - and so uh you know I like I
don't like being told what to do and I
don't like being told there's no options
I don't like being told it's always that
way everybody does it that way as soon
as you tell me that the first thing I'm
going to say uh-huh yeah but that's what
I want you to set that in your head be
careful of the language that you allow
your children to use in regards to this
if you've got a senior in high school oh
that don't you know everybody Oh soon as
you say that honey everybody is a bad
financial planner come on that day if I
don't get